let's get right into hatred mail no time
to waste hatred mail of course when a
professional voice-over artist does
interpretive readings of the hate mail
that I get quick reminder about hatred
mail it's like a mandatory transvaginal
ultrasound for your mind Patriot Man
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom and of course the typical sorts
of critiques we've heard before from
hatred mail this week let's take a
listen David Pakman get a life you're a
loser
David pac-man and his loser followers
pretend to be nuanced and individual
thinkers Trump is just the biggest
leader ever and the left Democrat losers
are just poor losers geoengineering
including chemtrails aka solar
remediation is the cause of climate
change David Pakman is a lying scumbag
loser you know this actually I think III
wouldn't say it gets to me but it does
make me question once again why do I
need to lie on the program I have no
boss who might fire me if I say the
truth the only people who hold me
accountable are the viewers and there is
no advantage to lying there is just no
incentive to do it and of course I can
get things wrong and people can disagree
with my conclusions but this idea that I
come on the program and deliberately lie
I don't even understand what there is
potentially to gain from that but yet it
is a common trope of hatred mail
remember that you can use the coupon
code hey tree at forty to sign up for
membership on our website at a 40%
discount you save 40 percent the hey
tree it's cry and independent media is
strengthened it's the trifecta that
coupon code is spelled HJ t RI o t four
zero you can use it on any membership at
join pakman.com to save 40% but you do
get 100% of the member benefits check it
out